je suis le chat potté
van damme flash à led
ben non
vous voulez voir l'autre gauche
razia star légendes ne meurent jamais
[Musique]
chapeauté tu es mort j'ai une vie nom
est tu es mort combien de fois déjà
en outre hôtel n'a pas besoin d'un par
heure regardez
regardez
toujours
tu es rendu à ta dernière vie malouda
est toujours à la recherche d'un nouveau
minet je ne laisserai pas abîmer ce soit
il laisse à porter ça c'était avant
mais c'est picasso
non
c'est le pot déçu m'a piqué il est là
petit coin c'est donc là qu'il faut
renoncer à toute dignité les macs et
enfin une tête de piqué ce
papa une tête des chats
pour d'accord j'avoue je suis un chien
de thérapie tu veux porter mon bidon
même pas un air
pur que dans les trois autres familles
de mafieux
mais la cause est
excusez moi ma chère on est à la
recherche du célèbre chat potté vous
savez peut-être il est c'est quoi un
chat potté
moi
logiquement j'ai aussi l'ebit ça change
tout j'étais riz 10
années
[Applaudissements]
ce sera juste parfait chasseur de primes
qui dit patte de velours j'ai besoin de
toi ça pouvait vite ça part en vrille
vous êtes un nouveau membre dans
l'équipe tulle j'étais habité jamais
jamais a quand même y arrivera
bon il faut que j'apprenne à faire ça
davy défilent devant des yeux un blanc
et la clémence du chat potté
à
[Musique]
esprit soir
je ne te crois pas fais moi confiance
est obligé de pas vu c'est si tu trouves
ça mais n'y ont
vu que les papattes moi chérie arrête tu
vas te foulée un oeil